اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم
استشهاد ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين برصاص
الاحتلال في نابلس حركه حماس نعتهم وقالت
انهم من كوادر القسام في الضفه وقضوا في
اشتباك المسلح والرئاسه الفلسطينيه تهدد
بحديثه الاغتيال وتصفها بجريمه حرب في وقت
يعم فيه اضراب شامل المحافظه حدادا على
ارواحهم
روسيا تشن هجوما بالمسيرات على كييف وتقول
انها احبطت هجوما على احدى سفنها بالبحر
الاسود وفي ملف الحبوب زيلينسكي يجدد
التاكيد انه سيوفر الحمايه للموانئ
والممرات في البحر الاسود بينما قالت
روسيا ان العوده الى العمل باتفاقيه
الحبوب مستحيله من دون مشاركتها
في استمرار لظاهره التطرف المناخي حرائق
الغابات متواصله في اليونان وعلى ضفتي
البحر المتوسط وتحصد عشرات الارواح في
الجزائر وزاره الداخليه كشفت انها نجحت في
اخماد غالبيه الحرائق بنسبه 80% بعد تاثر
السته عشر ولايه جزائريه بها
الامم المتحده تتحدث عن فشل عالمي في
الجهود الدوليه للحد من الجوع وتقول ان
اكثر من
780 مليون شخص يعانون من الجوع في كل
انحاء العالم في الوقت الذي يهدر فيه نحو
ثلث كميه الطعام في العالم او يتلف
فيما لا